اوكرانيا ترهب الاوروبيين. اذا
توقفتم عن دعمنا ستلتهم النيران
الروسية كل اوروبا. وبريطانيا
ترد بتزويد كييف بسلاح انجليزي.
قد يغير قواعد اللعبة ورد روسي
حاسم. الرجل الاصفر. لم يعد
لدينا ذخيرة في بلدنا. والسبب
اوكرانيا. الكرملين يعترف بصعوبة
الحرب الاوكرانية. اهي حقيقة ام
خدعة جديدة. وزلنسكي يعلن موعد
الهجوم المضاد. مائة وخمسون
قتيلا اوكرانيا خلال يوم واحد.
المعارك الفلسطينية الاسرائيلية
تشتعل واسرائيل تحت رحمة النيران
الغزاوية. ونتنياهو يطلب الوساطة
ومصر تتدخل. منافس اردوجان يعلن
انسحابه من الانتخابات. ومحكمة
باكستان تعلن براءة عمران خان.
فهل تفرج عنه السلطات? اوكرانيا
امام طريق مسدود. غموض يكتنف
الحرب تصريحات متضاربة وتدخلات
خارجية زادت الطين بلة. هجمات
برية وجوية. اسلحة تدخل لاول مرة
والمستقبل مجهول يا سادة. نعم.
انها المرة الاولى التي يعلن
فيها الكرملين ان العملية
الروسية في اوكرانيا صعبة ومعقدة
للغاية ولم تحقق اهدافها. فما سر
هذه التصريحات? تصريحات الكرملين
تزامنت مع تأكيد مجموعة ان مدينة
باخمود باتت عمليا تحت سيطرتها.
وبقيت فقط مسافة سبعمائة واربعين
مترا للسيطرة الكاملة عليها وفق
نوفوستي. الحرب الكلامية مستمرة
وكل يدلو بدلوه. وبعد تأكيد
الرئيس الاوكراني فلاديمير
زيلينسكي ان الهجوم المضاد لطرد
القوات الروسية من الشرق
الاوكراني لن ينطلق قريبا. قال
قائد قوات فاجنر الروسية
بريجوجان. ان الوحدات الاوكرانية
قد بدأت بالفعل هجومها لا سيما
في محيط باخموت واطرافها بحسب
رويترز. فهل الجيش الروسي قادر
فعليا على صد هذا الهجوم المنتظر
ام ان القوات الاوكرانية ستتمكن
من استعادة المنطقة بشكل كامل?
هنا تواصل كييف تصويب سهام حربها
الكلامية والهدف اوروبا هذه
المرة حيث حذر ميخائيل بودلياك
مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني الاتحاد
الاوروبي من امكانية اندلاع حرب
شاملة في اوروبا في حال التوقف
تقديم الدعم العسكري لكييف.
مضيفا انه لن يكون باستطاعة
الاوروبيين الجلوس في المطاعم
وتناول الكرواسون بهدوء. اول
المستجيبين لتحذيرات كييف كانت
لندن. حيث اعلنت العاصمة
البريطانية نقل صواريخ لاوكرانيا
ستغير قواعد اللعبة بشكل حقيقي.
وافادت قناة سي ان ان بان
بريطانيا نقلت صواريخ بعيدة
المدى من طراز كروز. لاوكرانيا.
مضيفة ان لندن تلقى من كييف
بانها لن تستخدم ضد اهداف في
الاراضي الروسية لتنفيذ ضربات
بعيدة المدى قبل الهجوم المضاد
المتوقع. فكيف سيكون الرد
الروسي? وبعد هذه الخطوة
البريطانية. هنا تصعيد روسي غربي
جديد يلوح في الافق. حيث حذر
المتحدث باسم الكرملين ديمتري
بيسكوف. من ان تزويد بريطانيا
لاوكرانيا بصواريخ كروز بعيدة
المدى يتطلب ردا مناسبا وحاسما
من الجيش الروسي. بينما صرح نائب
مجلس الدوما ديمتري بيليك بان
صواريخ ستورم شادو البريطانية
بعيدة المدى لن تكون السلاح
المعجزة بالنسبة لاوكرانيا ولدى
روسيا ما تجيب عليها به. لتلحق
بولندا ببريطانيا وتعلن بعثة
بولندا الدائمة لدى الاتحاد
الاوروبي عن نقل وارسو اربعة عشر
طائرة مقاتلة من طراز ميج تسعة
وعشرون الى اوكرانيا بانتظار
الرد الروسي. اما على الارض
وخلال المعارك الروسية
الاوكرانية افادت الدفاع الروسية
بتدمير اثني عشر مسيرة اوكرانية
في لوجانسيك ودوناتسيك
وزابوريجيا واسقاط مقاتلة
اوكرانيا سو خمسة وعشرون في
خراسون. وتصفية اكثر من خمسمائة
وخمسين جنديا اوكرانيا على كافة
المحاور خلال يوم واحد. فيما كان
رئيس هيئة ضباط روسيا لواء
الطيران سيرجي لي بوفو. قد صرح
بان اوكرانيا حاولت مهاجمة موسكو
في يوم عيد النصر بحوالي مائة
طائرة مسيرة تم تحييدها جميعا.
فماذا بعد هذا كله يا هؤلاء؟
وبعد هذا الكر والفر بين كييف
وموسكو ظهرت اثار ذلك في امريكا
لياتي الدور على الرجل الاصفر
دونالد ترامب والذي قال ان
الولايات المتحدة نقلت الكثير من
الاسلحة والذخيرة الى اوكرانيا
منوها بانه لم يعد هناك ذخيرة
كافية في البلاد. الرجل الاصفر
عاد واكد مجددا انه قادر على
انهاء الصراع في اوكرانيا تحت
رئاسته في اربع وعشرين ساعة، فهل
يستطيع ذلك؟ ام انه جرد دعاية
انتخابية. وبالعودة الى موسكو.
الروس لا يتركون تهديدات الغرب
تمر دون رد وان تأخر الرد قليلا.
هنا تعلن لجنة التحقيق الروسية
انها ستدرج قريبا على قائمة
المطلوبين قضاة المحكمة الجنائية
الدولية الذين اصدروا مذكرة
توقيف بحق الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين. ومن المعارك
القضائية الى حرب الطاقة
النووية. حيث افاد تقرير وول
ستريت جورنال بان بناء مفاعلات
نووية يشهد مؤخرا زخما في
الولايات المتحدة واوروبا. لكن
التقرير اشار في المقابل الى ان
الجانبين الامريكي والاوروبي ما
زالا عاجزين عن الاستغناء عن
الوقود النووي الروسي اللازم
لتشغيل تلك المفاعلات. فكيف
ستعوض اوروبا ما خسرته من الطاقة
الروسية. فلسطين تكشر عن
انيابها. ضربني وبكى وسبقني
واشتكى. هذا هو المثل العربي
يحكي حال الكيان الاسرائيلي بعد
ان تحرش بالمقاومة الفلسطينية
بغاراته وهجماته. ليرتفع عدد
الشهداء الى ستة وعشرين بينهم
خمسة من قادة سرايا القدس. اخرهم
عضو المجلس العسكري للسرايا.
احمد ابو دجة بعد استهداف منزل
في منطقة بني سهيلة جنوب شرق
قطاع غزة. وقال وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي. ان هدفهم هو قتل
اكبر عدد ممكن من قيادة الصف
الاول في الجهاد الاسلامي. ان كل
من يقف وراء اطلاق الصواريخ
باتجاه اسرائيل سيدفع ثمنا باهظا
جدا حسب تعبيره. لكن الواقع يقول
عكس ما يقوله وزير الكيان. حيث
دوت صفارات الانذار في ضواحي تل
ابيب الجنوبية بسبب رد ثأر
الاحرار الفلسطيني. تم ارغام
اكثر من مليوني اسرائيلي على
الذهاب الى الملاجئ. حتى ان
الجنود الاسرائيليين كانوا
يهربون بجانب الاعلاميين
للاحتماء من الصواريخ التي كانت
بعضها في السماء بفعل تصدي القبة
لها فيما مرت معظمها بسلام.
وافادت مصادر طبية اسرائيلية
بمقتل اسرائيلية واصابة اخرين
بالضربة الصاروخية الضخمة التي
وجهتها المقاومة الفلسطينية لعدد
من المدن الاسرائيلية. وهذا ما
ظهر يا اصدقاء لكن ما خفي كان
اعضاء. لتسارع تل ابيب لاجراء
اتصالات دبلوماسية خوفا من
التصعيد الفلسطيني. وطالبت
اسرائيل الامم المتحدة التوسط
لها. القاهرة تستجيب لهذه
المطالب. وعقدت مباحثات مع
الطرفين لكن وزير الخارجية
المصري. خرج بعدها ليحذر من
تدهور الاوضاع في فلسطين قائلا.
جهودنا لاحتواء الوضع لم تؤتي
ثمارها بعد. ليعقد رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو
اجتماعا طارئا بوزير دفاعه. لبحث
الضربات الجوية الاخيرة من قطاع
غزة ويطلب من الاسرائيليين
انتظار فهل هي تعليمات الذهاب
الى الملاجئ? احداث اليوم.
السباق الرئاسي التركي يقترب من
نهايته. هنا اعلن زعيم حزب البلد
محرم انجا انسحابه من المنافسة
في الانتخابات الرئاسية وذلك قبل
ثلاثة ايام من الانتخابات المقرر
اجراؤها الاحد المقبل. وذلك بعد
تسريبات اخلاقية نسبت له. قالت
المحكمة العليا في باكستان ان
اعتقال رئيس الوزراء عمران خان
لم يكن قانونيا ويجب اطلاق سراحه
فورا. الجزاء من جنس العمل. هكذا
اعلنتها المقاومة الفلسطينية بعد
ان امطرت اسرائيل بوابل من
الصواريخ. فهل يرضخ الكيان
للتهدئة?